I just wanted to jump on here for a quick second.
We just finished a Q P question period in the house
and I wanted to share with folks, uh,
what some of the members of the PC caucus were doing, uh,
during this last question period.
Before I get into that, it's important to know that actually
today is the start of Phase 4 of the landfill search
for Morgan Harris in Mercedes Myron.
The premiere was there yesterday with the families in ceremony
and the premiere was there early this morning
with those folks that are working
and are going to be actually doing the searching.
Today's a really important day.
Like it's a historical moment right now,
the start of this fourth phase of the landfill search.
And so during question period,
the cabinet ministers that were asked questions
took the opportunity to remind the PC caucus
what they did in the last provincial election
in the 2023 election.
And folks will remember it was a very hateful and divisive campaign.
But they also centered their campaign
over the question of searching the landfill.
They centered the campaign on the murders of indigenous women
by a serial killer,
you know, something that has never been done in politics,
really one of the most grotesque moments in politics.
And to this day,
each and every one of those PC caucus members that got elected
under that hateful
anti indigenous misogynistic election has never apologized,
has never apologized for What their election,
with their party, with their people did during that campaign.
And so during QP today, our members that got up
took the opportunity to remind them of what they did.
And while our folks were answering those questions,
I want to share with you what some of them were doing.
But let me start also just with last week.
The member for Turtle Mountain,
this guy said, yelled across the way and said,
it's in the past. Get over it.
It was literally 14 months ago today.
The member for Brandon West,
this guy, uh,
sat there smirking and laughing
while our cabinet ministers were getting up
and reminding them about their political campaign.
The member for Springfield, Rashad,
this guy was doing this to the premier.
Every time the premier was getting up
and reminding them of what they did,
he was going like this to the premier,
just being so dismissive about what the Premier was,
was bringing forward in the house.
The member for Swan River,
which I don't know why he's still in MLA
and you, all you have to do is just Google his name and what he did.
How he still in MLA, I don't know.
But the member for Swan River
throughout the whole QP was laughing and talking
every time members of our cabinet were getting up
and talking about the landfill search,
blatantly just laughing. The member for Red River North,
this guy who routinely has his back to The premier and to all of us
when we get up to answer his questions
was also doing the same gestures,
like just dismissing what we are bringing forward.
So why do I take the time to do this and share this with you?
Because it is important
for Manitobans to know that these folks have never said their story.
And these folks, up until literally 15 minutes ago,
still don't care and act with such contempt over indigenous women
who were murdered by a serial killer
and for their families. And I,
for one, and I know all of our caucus
will never let them forget what they did
during one of the most grotesque provincial campaigns in our history.
So I wanted to share that with you.